I won't bother with all the footballers
I well Bob Dylan's got to be there sort
of head and shoulders above anyone else
in terms of the way that hearing him has
influenced me and then there's a whole
battalion of people everyone from Nina
Simone to talk talk van morrison no Nick
Drake there's a Leonard Cohen you know
Joni Mitchell it's just a there's a
whole sway then I'll people like the
specials and the Cure cuz I was obsessed
with the cure for a jazz I loved them
saw them live a couple of times in the
mid-80s they were great
yeah there was a couple actually one was
the waterboys this is the sea at Cardiff
University 1985 they just went straight
through the curfew and played for like
three hours but that was such a
brilliant record and he was at the peak
of his powers Mike Scott at that point
they would he'd already written songs
like fisherman's blues and things that
appeared later and he played them at the
show I don't I remember instantly liking
that I've never heard it before and he
played a couple of things including a
couple of covers and he just went on and
on and on but the way they all changed
instruments that I loved that show and
then the same year i went to Glastonbury
for the first time and the Cure headline
Saturday night that was the head on the
door album which was a brilliant record
but they just did a brilliant set and it
was Glastonbury as it used to be not
quite as clean and neat and tidy as it
is now but the pyramid stage they had a
laser needs to be a later Wow the laser
only the headline act could use it so
the Cure got to use the laser and I was
there a bit out of me brains with my
little friend from school and as
thunderstorm came into the moon was
going down and like the Sun was of other
moons coming out the Sun was going down
and then this just this huge storm came
in and there was thunder and lightning
and all the dry ice was being dragged
across the stage it just looked
fantastic and they just played through
all this stuff yeah that was that was
amazing I was blown away by Glastonbury
the whole thing of it I'm so obsessed by
music I must have seen about 40 bands
but the cure was that was the best
you